foreign
movies and TV and see how effective they
are
[Music]
people think for granted how powerful
their hands are in a modern capoeira
practice we do have some strikes you can
use this part of your hand and you can
search as much as this if I go like this
up with full power it's devastating
[Music]
what they did is something we do very
common in capoeira we practice that
ahmada and typically you know we get
this close it should go fast and be able
to react
[Music]
their front kick bandsaw that was
beautifully done because he used your
upper body going
back he gained power he can make someone
fly like that Wesley's name is an
incredible guy incredible martial artist
because they've exaggerated us to keep
the nine
when we judging by the technical aspect
of perfect Latifah's incredible fighter
adding that spin
right it was his choice in the fighting
situation he will never do that in a lot
of the the presentations see in movies
you can only see on one part of capoeira
which is more the visual capoeira is an
African Brazilian martial art and was
brought from Africa to Brazil
but in Brazil because of slavery people
they had to practice cup with it
differently because was illegal to
practice so even today people are
completely confused about capoeira
because you see like beautiful movements
but the whole point is to disguise the
potential you have behind that
particular movement
when he did the cartwheel from the low
position he had to be also careful
because if he goes all the way in he'll
definitely hit the other actor
that one in the movie that he kicks back
and forth It's not a move they're gonna
see in a fight what I would say gets
people's confused up with it there's an
element of playfulness there's no right
over on some people use Mortal Kombat
other people know the playfulness
it's called half a moon the way that was
shot you just see they keep going like
this
because they're not allowed to go all
the way because it will be too fast for
him to get out and then their lure in
the real world really goes with the hill
with full speed
good luck with that he'll be standing up
right now I will give her nine if they
were very to the point
but for safety they had to pull back a
lot of stuff
great moment here you see when the he's
doing a cartwheel he using the acrobatic
as a way of attacking you can definitely
generate that card with your hands and
without your hands if you do without
their hands you get even more power
because you're just throwing your body
in such a force that's gonna swing very
hard in the face
that's why is escape but from that
escape typically you want to strike
because what you do after the Escape
that's the whole point the nature of cup
would escape and you have a follow-up
for that situation you're dodging then I
will throw a mealua which is a little
kick can be like anywhere from the leg
here or up to the head
no powers
so there's one very very typical way of
attacking capoeira is with the headbutt
and they're doing the different angles
like forward sideways backwards but this
was perfect because the only way you can
actually Strike Back was it using his
head butt
and there was a perfect example where he
did that scissors it's beautifully done
because it comes from the ground
I think is the only art
that it really use the floor the way we
did equally 50 50 standing and also use
the ground and then he went to the
choking which is more like Jiu-Jitsu
it's definitely the the capoeira
scissors allow the person to have the
opportunity to do the next thing there
were certain things that I would have
done differently like the escapes I'll
give a seven
it can be very fluid you can be for a
slow pace to super fast and do like five
six seven eight kicks like back to back
it can be super dangerous when you do
that and when you have the right timing
with that lower position that we call
High state of the sweep it can be done
but will be extremely hard especially if
you have someone like Batman she will be
more an advantage of waiting for him to
attack her and be responding instead of
being attacking all the time and using
techniques that would hit the chain be
more direct the groin the knee throat
I
to use the walls to to kick visually
it's great when you Telegraph when you
show what you're gonna do that means
your opponent will be ready to respond
it's not the cup with the nature of
showing like a snake in a snake will
wait for the right moment to to go I'll
give you a four and a half wait what is
it it's Capital error I thought maybe
you were doing it wrong but that's
actually what it looks like if you're
practicing this you know calling Jinga
you know that's silly if I'm practicing
Jinga basically the stent that you you
know you do your triangle I'm working my
posture
so I can block with my elbow I can block
down I can block up so you move you
escape attack from that Foundation if
you're just there doing this all day
it's pretty funny
even this entrance here is more like a
karate entrance just imagine some more
like doing karate and doing cartwheels
it's interesting
but definitely not over a presentation
what we're talking about
my name is gyro welcome to the world of
capoeira capoeira is the most seductive
form of self-defense it combines
peacefulness fighting and cardio and
they hold there for a second
peacefulness
it this to me it feels like more like a
yoga
capoeira King from struggles came from a
survival situation to be peaceful when
you're supposed to survive it's a
contradiction there
you can advance through the stages by
earning different colored chords at the
trocha J cordoves the rankings right
that became more
popular
a laid on what that traditionally wasn't
that way lots of other training were
done in the streets because certain
people they were able to survive
doing this combat
they became recognized
as a master or a teacher by the
community instead of someone just giving
you a ranking I'll give it one and a
half
foreign
way to use capoeira with lasers he's
using a lot of capoeirangola there are
two Styles capoeira Kapoor Angola which
you you're gonna see a lot of the
more fluid slow movements some people
can stand up as well but most people
they'll be more on the lower part of the
art the other style is called kapolejo
now that was introduced laid about a
master called Master bimba which you're
going to see more the strikes like the
other films that you saw and the
interest in this scene here that they
use a lot of that to avoid to be touched
not to be in control of anything and
just react to something that you see
today we see fall and be able to bounce
back without putting a lot of effort did
a good job as far as like using the
flexibility and the abilities that we're
capable of in capoeira I give eight and
a half
that's me when I used to have like long
hair people think that we actually doing
the fighting here we are doing the
hardest Circle to practice our skills if
you notice there's no contact because it
is more the training
so the music is a big part of capoeira
basically in a circle you have a battery
that means what they have the bidding
bow the drum so when you clap and when
you sing and when you play you create
more and more energy so you'll be able
to perform better even during slavery a
lot of times the music
was used to create courage to create
endurance to be able to fight against
the oppressors so the musicality is so
important talks about history
it talks about struggles how we're able
to overcome to become who we are today I
think
this film was the first movie that
actually
future capoeira from beginning to end
I'll give it 10 I'll give nine and a
half because I know there was a lot of
way to improve
welfare is such a funny guy I think the
capital here is definitely like overly
exaggerated you don't need to go over
but in a real situation it just simply
just go down
and then drop the character if you're
gonna spend that time just fly in the
air before it drops people can they have
many options to get out of the way and
do all the things
would it be interesting if it was the
bidding bow and he was like hitting
people then we'll be very accurate the
billing bowel is the main instrument in
capoeira but
using somebody's like bodies to do that
is pretty unrealistic this one that will
rate six and a half it's too much of his
exaggeration to complete one simple task
okay let's stop
historically is a great story but it
could go to a level that for me was
unnecessary bizotto it was an incredible
kapoorista traditional people that claim
that he was able to fly and
is very romantic but this scene here
completely unrealistic how can somebody
be shooting and you'll be flying the air
like that I can watch The Matrix and
appreciate that it's a whole different
story here
if you don't have three people
with rifles and used to be able to stand
up not very realistic but doable
capoeira came from that environment
finding multiple people is that
something that we know works but again
it depends how good you are how
effective you are
how you know efficient and their goals
with many other Arts you know not just
capoeira I will give you four my
favorite movie featuring capoire not
because I mean it but I think only
strong because there was the element of
the performance and now the actual
combat
to be able to use in a full length film
thanks for watching this video If you
like this one watch the one above